the warmest reception from his final
audience gaben didn't just entertain
this nation his broadcasting shipment
Presidents and Prime Minister's were
among the congregation his family
grateful for this public outpouring
thank you to all of you that have come
out today on the route from Hope which
was stunning and so lovely and a great
tribute to send him off he worked for a
time at Granada interviewing among
others the Beatles you think that
returned to Dublin to launch the show he
would host for four decades show we've
been joined now my friends by the most
controversial man in this country from
politics to show business okay this is
from us to you again he became a
household name tackling two moves
paving the way to a new Ireland he
changed everything as a broadcaster
because he wasn't just playing a few
discs on the radio and interviewing a
few pop stars on the TV he wanted it not
that whether he wanted to or not he was
a an instrument of change in a country
that needed that sort of guidance
Ireland has lost a national treasure
Gaye burns grandchildren the man they
called rah-rah Lord Jesus we want to
thank you for all the wonderful times we
had with whare and we were also very
grateful for the special last few days
we spent with him we pray Ferrara
the voice of the nation may have fallen
silent but its impact will resonate in
Ireland for generations it's been a
fantastic carousel I've enjoyed every
minute of it
god bless you all and good night thank
you for being a david leavens sky news
in Dublin